it's lab muffin beauty science here one
of the nerdiest beauty channels on
YouTube and today we're going to be
talking about whether the blue light
from screens like your laptop screen or
your phone screen is going to damage
your skin it's a valid concern because
if you're anything like me you wear a
ton of sunscreen and you're hyper aware
of your sun exposure but during the day
you're parked in front of a computer
screen and at night you take off all
your sunscreen and then stare at
electronic devices you've probably also
heard about how blue light hitting your
eyes can mess up your circadian rhythm
and sleep patterns I've recently posted
a video about how visible light can
damage your skin and how to protect your
skin against it I've linked it in the
caption below and it's a good idea to
watch that video first the key points
that you need to know from that video to
understand this video are visible light
can theoretically damage your skin
higher energy blue and violet light with
shorter wavelengths are the colors that
are the most harmful blue light causes
pigmentation in dark-skinned people but
in a different way from UV so you need a
different amount compared to UV to have
any sort of effect there are a few
ingredients that you can use to protect
your skin from blue light iron oxide and
antioxidants but sunscreen won't work
not even a really thick coat of mineral
zinc oxide or titanium dioxide sunscreen
so now let's look at the evidence is
watching this video making your skin
worse is lab muffin beauty science a
conspiracy to make your skin worse so
you really really need my skincare
advice
to answer this question first we're
going to have to work out how much blue
light we need to cause skin damage the
next little section is a bit of nerdy
math talk in case you're interested in
how I came up with these numbers if
you're not really into this and you just
want the results feel free to tune out
until the bouncing muffin face is gone
from the studies it seems that the total
amount of light energy hitting your skin
is the most important thing to look at
this is called the dose or flux and it's
measured in joules per square centimeter
to calculate how long you need to be
exposed to a light source to get that
particular dose I'm using the intensity
of the light or the irradiance which is
measured in watts per square centimeter
one watt is one Joule per second from
the studies on human volunteers so far
it's a little tricky because different
experiments use different wavelengths of
light but we can get a ballpark figure
from these studies you need at least 40
joules per square centimeter of light
for both visible and just blue light
it's not really useful to look at in
vitro studies where the skin cells were
in petri dishes since in real life your
skin isn't flat like that and there's
layers of dead skin protecting the
living cells underneath so real skin
should be able to handle more light next
let's look at how long it takes to get
this 40 joules per square centimeter
amount from the Sun the reason we want
to look at the Sun is that it's by far
the biggest source of visible light it's
way higher than the amount that you get
from screens or indoor lighting think
about how easy it is to see stuff in
your room during the day versus if
you're trying to see stuff by the light
of your phone screen at night the
intensity of sunlight depends on
location and the time of year
here are some approximate times it
takes to get that minimum 40 joules per
square centimeter of energy from the Sun
on dark skin to have a noticeable effect
if we're looking at the full spectrum of
visible light so all of the colors
together in summer in Texas it takes
about 13 minutes to get 40 joules per
square centimeter the average at ground
level
midday is about 15 minutes for blue
light in the US or southern Europe and
midday on average it takes about 40
minutes to get 40 joules per square
centimeter the light intensity in winter
is about one-third or two-thirds of the
amount in summer compared to sunlight
the measurements for screen light are a
lot more variable there's a lot of
different screens out there there are CRT
LCD LED monitors phones and different
tablets and the light they put out
depends on the brightness level you have
the screen set to the sorts of things
you're looking at so for example if
you're watching a dark and moody video
or playing a brightly-coloured game or
scrolling through your emails which have
a white background there's also lots of
different blue light filters and
different amounts of blue light that the
different screens put out I have a list
of the values I worked out for the time
so you need to get 40 joules per square
centimeter of light to get these numbers
from the studies and make them
comparable I had to make a bunch of
assumptions so they're probably not
really accurate they're only meant to
give us an idea of the relative times
you need for these levels of light I
have more details about the studies I
took the data from how I got to these
numbers and the assumptions are used in
the blog post that comes with this video
the average number of hours you need to
get 40 joules per square centimeter
of light on your skin from a screen is
somewhere around fifteen to thirty days
there's a bit of a catch here when we're
comparing these times screens tend to
produce more of the shorter wavelengths
of light that cause more damage than the
Sun does but even if we take the
worst-case scenario which is with an
iMac with a bright white screen it's
still over a hundred times less damaging
than the midday Sun and that's if we're
only counting visible light and
completely ignoring the UV and infrared
radiation from the Sun that also causes
damage if we take a four inch smartphone
with a bright white screen that's closer
to the middle of the range it's over two
thousand times less damaging than the
midday Sun so is visible light from
phones and computers worth worrying
about
for most people I would say no comparing
the amount of visible light from screens
to the amount from the Sun sounds really
scary but it's only scary because the
Sun also puts out UV which is what
causes most of the skin damage in the
Nambour study people who wore UV
protective sunscreen daily which had no
visible light protection had no
detectable increase in aging visible
light also hasn't been linked to any
noticeable changes in the skin apart
from one which is more pigment in people
with dark skin blue light does seem to
cause more free radicals in the skin but
it doesn't seem like this increase
directly translates to many of the
noticeable effects that we know that
free radicals have on the skin like
wrinkles and aging so until there's more
research out I wouldn't really panic too
much about visible light there are a
couple of situations I can think of
where you might want to watch out for
visible light if you're undergoing a
medical treatment where you're very
sensitive to visible light such as if
you're doing photodynamic therapy or if
your skin is darker Fitzpatrick four or
above and you want to fade pigment and
you're already wearing a sunscreen with
broad-spectrum coverage and it doesn't
seem to be doing enough then it might be
worth avoiding the Sun a bit more with
things like shade and protective
clothing and maybe it's worth turning
down the brightness of your screens a
little bit obviously this research is
still quite new so could well be that in
the next few years well
get a better idea of whether we should
worry about blue light and maybe there
will be something new that makes us more
cautious but for now it seems mostly
like it's a marketing craze that isn't
backed up by what the scientific
evidence says and that's all about blue
light from screens in your skin I hope
you like this video if you did you can
subscribe to this channel for more
science-based beauty talk and follow me
on Instagram and Facebook and on my blog
on my blog you can also check out lots
and lots of science-based beauty
articles and I also have a free guide to
exfoliation which is a fantastic thing
to add to your skincare routine if you
want smooth glowing skin thanks so much
for watching see you next time for more
science and nerding